The number one question I get
is how to play up your eyes.
I'm going to show
you the smoky eye.
The smoky eye is layered.
Do not get a dark black shadow
and put it all over your eye.
My makeup philosophy is
that I like it to be quick.
I like it to be natural.
It's not about how you look.
It's about what
you do look like.
Makeup is a way to
change the way you feel,
make you comfortable in your
skin, and enhance who you are.
I love when she smiles,
you see the little lines.
And you know what?
We have lines.
And that's okay.
You have to embrace
yourself, embrace your age.
No matter what color skin you
have, what color eyes you have,
what color hair you
have, anyone could
make themselves look beautiful.
I'm going to teach you how to
cover up the little pesky spots
on your face, how to use
anything from a pencil,
to a cream, to even coconut oil.
This is like an ideal treatment.
Bronzer 101.
Use a wide brush.
Dip the brush in, tap it.
Blow to get it off.
And that way, you don't
make a mess on the skin.
All right.
Let's do your eyes first.
Now, make sure
you're blending it.
Fingers are the
best way to blend.
Oh, I love this.
I would like to demystify
your makeup kit.
You need a moisturizer, black
mascara, four shadows, a brush,
a pencil, and that's
pretty much it.
Makeup should not be a mask.
Makeup should not
change the way you look.
You don't wear foundation to
change the color of your skin.
You don't contour your nose.
There is nothing
wrong with your nose.
You don't overline your lips.
Makeup should
enhance who you are.
She doesn't need anything else.
She looks absolutely gorgeous.
You're going to call
me every day, right?
BOBBI BROWN: Yeah, every day.
I'm Bobbi Brown, and
this is my MasterClass.